We often think that a knowledge of
operating systems, security, networking,
and other technologies is our most
important skills when trying to
troubleshoot a problem. But in reality,
communication tends to be the issue
where people tend to run into problems.
And in a way, this does make sense. We
do spend a lot of time trying to
understand the nuances of the latest
operating system or the internals of a
particular application. But how often do
we spend time really understanding how
to communicate with other people? One of
the things that I have realized during
my career in IT is that the
communication skills that you have are
extremely marketable. And the better you
are at communicating with other people,
the higher you'll move up within the IT
ranks. In technology, we love to
abbreviate. Our acronyms tend to be
littered in all of our documentation,
and we tend to use shortcuts and
abbreviations when describing technology
topics. When you're communicating with
other technologists, those abbreviations
are perfectly reasonable. But when
you're discussing problems with a third
party or with your customer, it might be
better to use a different set of terms.
Your goal is to be the translator
between the technical world and the
world that they work in. And very often
this means that you're avoiding any use
of acronyms or any technological slang.
The people in charge of the organization
have not spent their entire career in
the world of information technology, but
they are very good at taking all of the
information in and making a business
decision. Your goal should be to present
the information in a very easy to follow
form that anyone would be able to
understand. Thankfully, this is a
problem that's relatively easy to avoid.
You just have to put yourself in the
shoes of the other person and explain it
as if you were someone who is not
involved in the world of technology.
The attitude that you have during your
normal workday is infectious. If you
have a positive attitude, you'll find
that the people around you also have a
positive attitude. When you're
communicating with other people, you
should be partnering with them and
talking with them as an equal. This is
something that will provide confidence
and show people that you are willing to
do the work. This can also help when you
run into those rare technology problems
that simply can't be resolved. If
someone has stored all of their personal
information on a storage drive and that
storage drive has failed with no ability
to recover any of that information, it
becomes a difficult conversation. But it
always helps if you maintain a positive
attitude and give people different
options for moving forward from this
issue. We're very often working with
these customers many times a day over a
number of weeks or even months. So, it's
important to keep in mind that your
attitude has a direct impact on the
overall customer experience.
As humans, we have a desire to be the
smartest one in the room and to make
sure that people understand that we know
this technology that we're working with.
But what we don't want to do is
interrupt people when they're in the
middle of describing the problems that
they're having or the issues associated
with a particular ticket. So we should
work on getting into a habit where we
spend much more time asking questions
and listening than we do talking and
interrupting. There have been many times
where customers try to explain a
particular problem and the technologist
interrupts before they even get to the
key point of the issue. We sometimes
assume we know what the issue happens to
be, but until we've heard the entire
story, we can never know for sure. This
is not only important when you're face
tof face with an individual, but it's
especially important when you're on a
conference call or a phone call. You
want to be sure that the person you're
talking to knows that they've been
heard, and you want to be sure that you
collect all of the important details
that will help you solve this problem. I
found this to be a very difficult skill
to perfect, not only for myself, but for
other people that I've worked with. But
if you spend your time understanding
when would be the appropriate time to
listen and when the appropriate time
would be to talk, you'll find that the
entire troubleshooting process moves
along much smoother.
Another thing that we don't tend to
spend enough time doing is asking
questions about what the customer is
seeing. They are the way that we drill
down into the details of the problem.
And very often we assume or make a
judgment call on what we think the
problem might be, but in reality we
should have asked more probing questions
to understand details about the issue. I
also find a useful task is to listen to
everything the customer is telling me
about the issue, make notes on exactly
what they're saying, and then repeat
back to them the information that I
heard. Often this matches exactly what
they've said, but sometimes they will
clarify a point that I may have gotten
wrong. This is not only an important
part of building good teamwork, but it's
also an important part of solving the
problem. Even after the customer spent
their time talking about the issue, and
you might even have a very good feeling
of what might solve this problem, it's
often good to ask clarifying questions
to see if perhaps it's not exactly what
you were thinking at first. You might
often find that what you believe the
problem to be originally is very
different in reality.
It's often said that expectation is
reality and there's no better truth than
when you're working on a technical
problem. It's always good to give people
options and have them understand what
the potential might be in almost any
scenario. For example, there may be an
option to repair a system or it might be
an option to replace. You should explain
both sides of this situation and have
them understand what the advantages and
disadvantages might be of either
decision. I also find it useful to
follow up with a technical conversation
over the phone using email. This way,
the problem itself is well documented
and both parties are on the same page
because everything has been documented
in an email. Sometimes these issues may
drag on for weeks or even months,
especially if you're waiting on parts to
be delivered by a manufacturer. One
thing you might want to do is set a
reminder in your calendar to have this
customer contacted once a week. Even if
we've not heard anything from the
manufacturer, we can still let the
customer know that we are still involved
with troubleshooting this issue and we
haven't forgotten about them. This is a
very simple thing to do, but it can be
very important for making people
understand that you are on top of the
problem and you're going to take care of
resolving their issue. And after you
close a ticket, it's always a good idea
to check in with the customer and see if
their problem really was resolved to
their satisfaction. Very often, they'll
say there's nothing else to do, and you
can continue to the next ticket. But
occasionally, they'll mention that there
is one extra thing that needs to be
resolved to get this to 100% resolution.
And that might have been a minor issue
that could have been easily resolved
that would have otherwise slipped
through the cracks.